lannoy accueilli france bonjour et
bienvenue dans l'entretien sur france24
notre invité aujourd'hui petro
porochenko il a été président d'ukraine
entre 2014 et 2019 il est avec nous
depuis kiev bienvenue dans l'émission
prochain les soldats ukrainiens sont en
train d'être évacués de l'usinage opstal
à mario paul dakoury d innsbruck et ils
sont évacués vers des territoires
contrôlés par la russie est ce que vous
êtes inquiets de leur sort
bien sûr d'abord
sont aujourd'hui un symbole du courage
un symbole de l'héroïsme non seulement
de l'ukraine mais de l'ensemble du monde
imaginez vous que cela fait 80 trois
jours qu'ils n'ont pas de nourriture
d'eau de munitions ils ont continué à
combattre
face à vingt mille soldats russes pour
les empêcher de développer leurs
opérations dans d'autres directions tout
d'abord je souhaite remercier le
secrétaire général des nations unies
antonio guterres est ce pour ses efforts
le président du cicr peter manoir
le président turc que monsieur erdogan
et tous ceux qui ont fourni un effort
colossal pour évacuer les soldats
ukrainien mais je vous en prie ne faites
pas confiance à poutine
poutine a jeté en prison les héros
ukrainien à aller 9 cas
cette situation
que le monde entier et l'ukraine
souhaite savoir quand ces soldats
ukrainiens seront libérés quand ils
seront de retour en ukraine et nous
devons concentrer nos efforts pour faire
pression
nous devons connaître les conditions
les conditions de cette évacuation des
soldats ukrainien sdao stahl
nous avons également besoin de vérifier
les conditions de détention des re
criant because a dit en effet parce
qu'il ya déjà des appels à la douma
moscou pour que ces prisonniers soient
poursuivis en justice est ce que vous
croyez que les autorités ukrainiennes
ont obtenu de très fortes garanties
que valent ces garanties quand elles
viennent de la part de vladimir poutine
écoutez je ne dispose pas de cette
information il voudrait sans doute mieux
poser cette question aux négociateurs
ukrainiens selon été impliqués dans ce
processus je ne souhaite absolument pas
commenter ce sujet nous ne permettrons
pas de faire des commentaires sur ce
sujet mais pendant cinq ans j'ai négocié
avec poutine de 2014 à 2019 et voici ce
que je recommande encore une fois nous
ne faite jamais confiance à poutine
poutine m'avait promis de relâcher naga
ça tient qu à lexington et tous les
autres et je souhaite vous rappeler que
nous avons sortis des prisons russes
plus de 3000 civils
l'ukrainien et militaires ukrainien
voilà ce que cela signifie face à cette
situation le monde doit être unie et se
souvenir que les soldats ukrainien à
azov asos talent se bat pour notre
liberté pour notre démocratie pour
repousser les russes à l'intérieur des
frontières reconnues de la fédération de
russie et vous avez parfaitement raison
les échanges que et ont eu lieu hier à
la douma au parlement russe où l'on
parlait de torture et les héros
ukrainien voilà la façon dont réfléchi
poutine voilà comment réfléchissent
c'est députés russes fou qui hier ont
émis cette dangereuse proposition
à wasnes-au-bac de revenir à la
situation plus généralement sur le
terrain
la russie s'est retiré de kiev où vous
êtes de quartier mais elle semble faire
des progrès dans le donbass
il semble être presque en contrôle de
cette région est ce qu'on se dirige vers
une partition de l'ukraine avec la
russie qui contrôlerait totalement le
don bas
d'abord il ne sèche pas d'un retrait de
la russie il s'agit du travail des
forces armées ukrainiennes et je suis
fier que d'avoir en tant que président
crée ses forces armées depuis 2014 car
c'est armé est l'une des plus fortes en
europe
et aujourd'hui nous payons un prix
extrêmement élevés pour les repousser
deux territoires entourant kiev
entourant tchernihiv soumis poltava et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de les
combattre pour les repousser de kharkiv
et cela prouve que aujourd'hui cela fait
presque douze semaines presque trois
mois et e poutine qui avait promis de
saisir l'ukraine en trois jours
c'est lorsque j'étais commandant en chef
des forces armées ukrainiennes que nous
avions repousser les troupes russes dans
deux tiers du territoire du dombass en
2014 nous sommes donc expérimenté de ce
point de vue là et vous avez
parfaitement raison
lorsque vous dites que
les russes ont mis en place des contre
offensives des contre attaques et cela a
lieu près de roubaix jna prêt de cd
radio net
ils ont pris pop hasna et nous
comprenons à quel point il est difficile
de mener ces combats mais nous
souhaitons vous rappeler que plus de 28
mille soldats russes resteront pour
toujours sur notre territoire pour payer
pour cette idée folle de vouloir se
saisir de l'ukraine à cette idée du
président russe
plus de 4500 chars russes et véhicules
blindés de transport de troupes russes
et plus de 350 avions et hélicoptères
russes et pourquoi est-il possible
maintenant non seulement d'arrêter mais
de contre-attaquer dans ces directions à
kharkiv kiev grâce à votre aide
grâce aux armes lourdes que nous devons
au moins en recevoir l'héritage les
trois sets les missiles anti aériens
l'artillerie anti char et je souhaite
vous rappeler que ce qui changerait la
donne ce serait 500 chars ou 1000
véhicules blindés de combat sans avions
de combat 300 missiles anti aériens qui
changerait l'avenir de l'europe cela
changerait la sécurité internationale et
nous comptons sur votre soutien nous
attendons votre soutien et hier lors de
l'entretien téléphonique entre le
président et l'inscrit le président
macron nous avons activé cette
coopération car ce dont nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui pour la sécurité
mondiale ces deux trois choses des armes
des armes et des armes des armes lourdes
et anti-aérienne des embargos et des
sanctions et la dépolitisation de la
russie poutinienne voilà
d'après ce que le président volodymyr
les hellènes ce qui aurait déclaré à un
média italien il n'était pas content que
le président français lure indiqué qu'il
fallait faire des concessions
diplomatiques
à la russie est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le président ukrainien et
est ce que vous pensez qu à ce stade
l'europe ne devrait même pas parlé à
vladimir poutine
expire écoutez j'ai une expérience
extrêmement positive de mon travail
conjoint avec les deux présidents
français avec qui j'ai travaillé
françois hollande et emmanuel macron
je souhaite vous rappeler que le premier
geste de soutien a été d'annuler le
contrat sur le les mistral français que
vous aviez promis de fournir à la russie
imaginez vous que la russie aujourd'hui
et c'est mistral porte-hélicoptères cela
signifierait que il aurait pu attaquer
odessa que la situation serait bien plus
difficile le président macron est un
grand ami de l'ukraine c'est un homme
politique expérimenté et aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin d'une meilleure
compréhension de la situation
d'abord nous ne ferons pas de
concessions voilà le message que nous
adressons à tous les dirigeants du monde
libre il n'y aura pas de concessions sur
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
cela reviendrait à proposer à la france
de donner à poutine la provence où la
corse pour défendre la stabilité
ensuite on ne doit pas flatté
l'agresseur
l'armée russe aujourd'hui ne combat pas
l'armée ukrainienne seulement elle viole
elle torture elle commet des massacres
contre des femmes contre des enfants
contre des personnes âgées et cela nous
ne l'oublierons jamais nous ne
pardonnerons jamais nous faisons de
notre mieux pour que notre pays
réintègre la famille européenne
nous faisons de notre mieux pour
intégrer l'otan dieu et pour faire de
l'europe un continent sur ndaw car il
est impossible de combattre une nation
dans le monde qui souhaitent la paix
plus que la nôtre aujourd'hui
il y a des négociations politiques des
négociations diplomatiques mais
également un combat par les forces
armées mais il faut séparer c'est une
négociation diplomatique
et encore une fois cela vient de mon
expérience dans les négociations avec
poutine d'abord il faut qu'il y ait un
cessez le feu immédiat et inconditionnel
un retrait des troupes russes et une
résolution de tous les problèmes
humanitaires la libération des otages et
toutes les autres questions ensuite il
faut des conditions pour la sécurité et
si la russie veut des garanties nous
ferons de notre mieux pour apporter sa
garantie à la russie et je souhaite
réitérer une invitation
à notre grand ami de l'ukraine mon ami
le président français emmanuel macron de
venir nous voir à kiev en effet il est
extrêmement important de passer de ce
que l'on peut se représenter à la
réalité du terrain pour voir le désastre
à bout de chagas tommy labeyrie janka à
andreev cas avoir des acquis tchernigov
ou encore acquiesce
j'ai passé les 83 derniers jours à kiev
et tous les jours toutes les nuits nous
avions des missiles de croisière qui tué
des dizaines de civils nous savons ce
que cela signifie et nous restons unis
nous gardons notre solidarité avec la
france et avec le monde petro porochenko
je vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous depuis kiev et merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cet entretien sur nos
antennes
[Musique]